hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I'm with Moreau no do you remember
when we did the video about iPhone cases
that were just tragic that was so funny
this is not his fence this is not me
Justine is now a veterinarian she is
performing surgery as we speak in those
animal would think some of them are so
adorable and some of them are greatly
terrible so I thought to go with that
row just got a new laptop when you end
the 13 inch so I also have got any
laptop fairly recently this is a 15 inch
but I thought I would get some really
crazy wild laptop cases it was actually
kind of hard to find my laptop cases
well like I don't need to get one ones
that weren't nice like I was looking for
luckily I've got a new laptop and I
actually did not want to tell you
Justine I can tell I wanna tell you
because the laptop that I had before my
Mac laptop I had had it for eight years
and it was so old that it stopped
updating if I would have known every
whenever she asks her to get I would
have picked you up and taking you to the
Apple store I would be like girl we're
going I think I would be carrying you in
cradling you like this and be like she
needs a computer unacceptable when
you're my friend
yeah I have a new computer so good proud
okay do you want to pick one first okay
shiny and then liking it so some of
these are bad but some of them are cool
like I thought flat a picture of this I
thought it was gonna be terrible but
it's actually really cool and confession
I've never had a laptop case ever like
when I'm traveling I just shove it in my
suitcase I am surprised that you're put
into your suitcase shove it in there
wait you still you don't have like a you
put do you check it do you check your
laptop like am your insult wait you've
got to turn it off you you Chesire
laptop thanks spinning I am the old one
you know where the disk is spinning the
whole time because I forget to turn it
off and so it's just like I'm stressing
isn't it a miracle that it's lasted
eight years I think that in an oven
self is just like kind of an ode to how
cool that computer was just break your
laptop in your checked luggage so like
you pick up you take off the spinny
thing if you check that night job I'm
not okay the new and I'm going to bring
it with me in my carry-on you'll be so
proud
maybe you hit the new case you can have
this it might be a little big but I
actually really like this one
okay it's squishy oh I like the smell
well it's no it smells nice most
definitely smells new I also like that
it has this little thing here too it's
like a little zip what's this for I
can't believe the first one that we
picked is actually really good these are
supposed to be terrible we just thank
your luck we didn't fit going like you
put your iPad in here you could put your
your charger I like to zip her to do
that first when you travel so nothing
falls out well you check your laptop
yeah so nothing falls out yeah people
can steal it like I hope you miss you
huh you don't ever put like super
valuable things in check luggage uh
you're right so this one I actually
really like I so you know this gets a
thumbs up from me
mhm what let us know is this a thumbs up
or a thumbs down I don't like your
thumbs up because I'm a fan of
functionality and it's squishy
it's really I am I thought it was gonna
be trash it's beautiful it's actually a
lot better than I was expecting me to
but you got you're not looking I mean I
could spell totally a box what is I
don't know okay we've got to test this
now this looks industrial what is this
oh oh wow it hard think you might be
bulletproof
no problem are you kidding no oh this is
heavy do this is super industrial so
let's close in here one of the things
that I do like it's look it's got all
these little pockets and stuff too okay
well where do you put the laptop thank
you sir
here so look that goes in there and then
you've got these little pockets for
quite poor very durable pretty durable
okay looks a little funny looks both
fruits but it seems pretty durable it
does this is huge how heavy is it it's
for him I mean that's pretty heavy
there's a computer in okay let's see how
that is without it it's Olivia yeah I
got too bad not too bad I wish it was
like something cooler on it well we
could do some DIY I ain't going
crossbones is not mine here they put one
what do I got it is a unicorn dabbing
yes
wouldn't you printed that what is so
there's like this weird site that just
Auto generates pictures then prints on
demand this is it's a fun image but the
image is really poorly printed like
bleeding speckle this is trash gotcha
it's a stupid fence yes it does fit so
look at this this is garbage it's
getting bigger it's I like it it's
brand-new and it's already falling apart
falling apart or pre quality and falling
apart I am NOT into things falling apart
right where you buy that this is brand
new
give me a few months trash that's the
trash pot yeah you go over there oh okay
so maybe I'll actually order this for
myself I love Hershel look I'm keeping
beautiful and it matches all the luggage
packs tie inners if ur is pink is this
pink it's like a little inner lining oh
it's eating a British color and look
feel how quality this is he's spicy
oh my gosh get in there okay can't in
there do you fit yeah I don't want to
take my computer out of this because
it's so perfect is this its new home it
is
I'm really impressed by meat okay okay I
guess not good one
what do we got what steaks oh listen
wine cork it looks like a cork Horace
oh my god it's so weird feeling it is
like cork Barney what is cool oh oh it's
very sly right it's very smooth it's
like cardboard
okay zipper in the front does that's
nice it writes on the inside like
popcorn it's soft agent yes your finger
in there okay borderland it's uh
zipper why does it do this it's like a
three-quarter zipper they couldn't put
it all the way down I mean it's probably
because they don't want when you put
your computer in and slide out the other
side okay okay that makes sense this one
does it too but it comes to you know oh
yeah other than the weird feel but this
is nice the inside the detail it's weird
I probably never would have bought this
thinking it was gonna look cool like I
kind of liked it I like the inside yeah
that my favorite part I liked a little
extra storage pocket here this texture
is a little weird feeling and I feel
like I could just tack pin little
post-it notes like on a message for you
know what this reminds me of what
YouTube like seven years ago when people
were using a lot of cork board for their
banners oh yeah like a little like
post-it note like this was like a theme
it was creative a point for creativity
I'm putting it in the nice pile all
right okay I'm not gonna even debate
that I thought these were all gonna suck
but I only one guy's your products are
so many ringer what do I pick what's
this oh it's this rose gold it is so why
is it so flat well what are you because
why is this it's well it's like a paper
sleeve
have sleeve what is that looks like what
it's not a case it's just like a like a
ugly out and I got a small protection
like a little bit okay I feel a little
dumb because I've never seen this lace
no now you have let's open it up okay
this one looks nice cool I never see you
usually things online look really cool
then you get it and it sucks all of
these look like trash online and now
there's no zipper no it's a sleeve it's
it's a sleeve this little girl this was
like an envelope it's uh slightly I
could print out a printer paper a little
letter to you and then I put it in here
and I mail it to you and I'm like it's a
sling you just seen you're invited to my
birthday party
Justine here and I have my halloween
party like this does look like a big
gamble on it does ear mail me a laptop I
said how can you even fit in there it's
a sleeve well where's the protection
there's no protection so this would be
something follow me this is something
like I would put in like an art like in
my laptop bag already like in my
backpack and put this in there because I
wouldn't want it to get like scratched
is usually I throw like I'll throw my
Mac and PC laptops together let's leave
this for it yeah if you're putting it in
your backpack yeah horse on an old case
did you pick this one I do I picked this
one I did okay I can't forget it I
picked it up and I was like this can't
be a case it's real so thin I would have
to actually try this out to get into it
yeah I can put it in the okay pile I
like it you're an expert your tech
expert so if you're saying this is a
thing yeah I totally believe it and it's
a nice thing it's a nice quality good
coloring the detail man okay what else
what else this one is supposed to be
like weather and waterproof resistant
something works
whether food yeah but it like to say all
says it's like one of those dry bags
like when you go camping and stuff the
planets best waterproof gear since 1996
that's me too that long so you could
bring it on a boat however it was
raining it's waterproof yeah so I was
thinking that when I saw this I was like
this size but it opens up like this oh
yeah sweet little bit water and then
another bag it's - I think that's for a
customer this see up there for anybody
it's cool in the back impressions
waterproof bag seems pretty fancy if you
can't afford this you can just do this
that is holes in it so you zip lock it
okay and then you should be waterproof
this 1996 Wow
do homes yeah I got a I got a garden
hose right I was saying we could spray
it can we spray it
yes it's waterproof since 1996's this
we're outside Noel's got a hose yes I
got home I've got the laptop case so
we're gonna put it in here and I'm gonna
make sure I ziplock it really really
close it cuz I'm really gonna spray it
we're gonna test this thing out nice and
tight yep
wonder if this is dunk proof like should
definitely try it oh are you serious
yeah why not
it says it's waterproof since 1996 it's
not well
oh my gosh I can't believe we're gonna
do that alright now I'm gonna get hos
these on too high the pressure is up too
hot okay I'll do the other side I really
ain't lit down here
[Music]
[Applause]
okay this is what we're here for
I feel like you you came over to my
house I should have held that
waterproofing the planets best gear all
right here we go oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my I'm so confident I'm so
confident this bag I'm not even that
nervous like I actually this is my
laptop like I don't like I don't even
have it backed up I'm that's how
confident I am in this dumb bag should I
let's see okay if this works
aqua quest you're the best if it doesn't
I hate you all right ready I can't
believe it ah this is for real oh yeah
what we does it really floats yeah it's
like a life vest
yeah oh that's nice that it reloads okay
only I'm gonna dunk it all the way in
those seams I'm just hoping that this is
okay he's very concerned if they're
ruined we can film some fun one I think
is make up for it we'll time some more
so confident in this like it's not even
funny like this is so zip-locked
[Music]
he's here to help I was not even worried
at all hookie can you smell or sense if
it is it was perfect
it's only but for my fingers like I want
the ice it was not even a bit worried
okay because I was terrified like what
if this did not work
oh yeah it's dry on the inside the only
part words wet is where I just touched
it yeah yeah this case it's only wet see
where I touched it but everywhere else
it's dry I fell for their marketing the
world leader in waterproof alcorta it's
true this case gets a thumbs up for me I
was very concerned but we have dusted it
what if it didn't work that was so brave
of you okay we're okay okay let's go to
work
we've got some work anywhere check out
let's go get some more cases well that
was fun yeah
well this one's hard it's it's very it's
ho what is it oh this looks like it's
like a donation I think it's a towel cap
I think so
so this even has a laptop cover like the
keyboard cover like how do we okay let's
take this off this is not Collison it
does not that it's not fit for little
Baker oh it fits a 15 ok by perfectly
you mean you don't fit that does not fit
at all
maybe if I close it up maybe that's why
oh that looks terrible 15 inch yeah this
is 15 and it does not fit does the
keyboards fit no it doesn't it because
there's also the touch bar so you have
to guess where the touch bar means
you're like let me just flip this down
and then guess this is so gross I
absolutely like I I hate this so much I
don't say that I hate things very often
I am ready for some why did you just
surprise me it is a pink mossy oh this
is total autumn vibe okay is it soft
inside it's not what there's the zippers
is this their logo I just thought I
think it might be their logo cuz they're
a little harder for me to grip is a
little bit big oh my gosh that's an inch
you guys this is an inch I think it was
like 15.6 inch case but I don't like the
quality but I'm really surprised because
I thought that I was gonna hate every
single one of these except for the
Camelot there yeah
it's a good fit well thank you so much
for joining me in this video
congratulations on your new computer
thank you guys do not check your
laptop's in your luggage oh right it
hurts my heart whoever do that right so
weird just don't ever do a shot well
thank you for joining me this video if
you guys want to find out any more
information about any of these cases
I'm literally surprised how nice these
are I will put links in the description
also put links to ROS channel make sure
you go check out hers we did some fun
videos on her channel too for Henze okay
okay thanks for watching go check out
his channel subscribe ding the bell do
all the things and we'll see you guys in
our next video also if you haven't
checked out the video where we did awful
life in pieces also put that link yeah
in the description yeah it was amazing
it was good
[Music]